My husband has been asking me to make him Oreos for a while now,
but I finally decided to make some
because I wanted my kids to know what an Oreo is.
I don't trust any of the ultra processed
snack foods for my growing children's health,
which is why I'm making them from scratch
using an ancient wheat as the base of the cookie cookie.
I'm using iron corn wheat because it has so much flavor,
satisfies, and hasn't been altered in the lab like modern wheat.
I gradually added in my flour and black cacao powder
to ensure the cookies would be black
rather than brown.
Since I used only four tablespoons of unrefined coconut sugar,
the dough wasn't sweet at all,
but that's fine because the filling would be rather sweet.
After rolling it out between two pieces of unbleached Parchment paper
to a 1/4 inch thickness,
I used a circular cookie cutter to shape each cookie.
I then carefully peeled off the leftover dough
and used it to make the remaining cookies
while those baked at 350 degrees Fahrenheit for 13 ish minutes.
I prepared the filling using 100% pasture raised raw butter
homemade on my parents farm,
combined with maple sugar and vanilla to make a fluffy such a filling!
Now don't let anyone tell you that homemade frosting isn't better!
The final part of this recipe
included
piping the frosting into the center of my fully cooled Oreo cookies.
This part was really exciting
But I had to contain myself since the cookies were fragile.
I had just picked the girls up from school,
so they were keen to try the Oreos, too.
And I couldn't help dancing to Backstreet Boys.
That my five year old somehow is into right now.